ha trabajado 24 años en Miri el
instrumento infrarrojo del telescopio
James webb y mientras un gran público se
maravilla ante la nebulosa de la Karina
el especialista sexta hacía sobre el
espectro gráfico del exoplaneta west96b
lo que llamamos espectroscopia es decir
descomponer la luz y ver el rastro de
las moléculas entre otras eso va a ser
donde la física se hará con el James
webb
la física
en diferentes exoplanetas los planetas
fuera del sistema solar ya se ha
detectado agua nubes y dióxido de
carbono
la otra gran Misión del James webb es
estudiar las Galaxias más antiguas como
esta de acá
en este compartimento
nicolegas su rapidez y su movimiento
ese también es el objetivo de la ciencia
eso nos permite obtener información de
lo que necesitamos e ir un poco más
lejos de lo que podríamos ver en
imágenes si fuera cualquier imagen
podría ser la pintura de un niño
pero el James webb también tiene una
vocación política el 11 de Julio pasado
el presidente estadounidense Joe biden
en persona reveló la primera foto del
telescopio
en el observatorio de la code está
puesta en escena hace sonreír a Enrique
esto permitió a muchas personas darse
cuenta que es algo importante creo que
el hecho de que fuera Joe biden el
primero que hizo una conferencia para
mostrarlo es algo que nunca había
sucedido para un evento astronómico un
año después de su lanzamiento del
telescopio espacial James webb ya
sobrepasa las expectativas
inicialmente previsto para funcionar una
década podría ser operativo por 20 años
[Música]